everybody Sean McGinnis here alongside
Sachs Pearson the executive producer on
project spark sex I hear that you have
some pretty cool user-generated content
to show us today yeah like we've been up
with a beta for about two months now and
people have been making amazing stuff
and every day in the office is like us
in wonderment looking at like how did
people pull this off we're going to be
showing you and some of the some of the
levels that we are just like falling
over ourselves over this first one is a
pinball level so somebody made like
looks like a village but as you're
swimming back you get to see that it's
actually a pinball table so in a bit of
instructions and then you get to fire a
boulder straight into the village and
like any good pinball table it has the
bumpers it has side rails it has like
all these like the things that make
pimples special like you can have the
secrets you can unlock part on the table
there's the analog game you can get to
if you unlock all parts of the table you
can take the clock tower in the center
and put it down and get obstacles in the
way we hear the creator's working on
seasons right now so it's going to be
like your winter season that's going to
be like a rainy season like this sort of
thing like totally like taking pinball
to the mill and to the next level no the
reason this is interesting for anybody
who hasn't seen projects bar before
project spark is not a pinball creator
game it's it's a lot more than that what
how exactly do you just described what
project spark is and how it leads to
something like this projects bak is a
game about making games like we say that
it's where players create and creators
plate it's a giant playground we provide
technology a place for the community to
be a sharing platform and all the pieces
that you build with and then it's up to
you like whatever you want to make you
can make here's another game it's a
puzzle game with it's completely unique
mechanic whenever you move the white one
the black one moves opposite of it and
it's about bringing the two thoughts
together and the level designs get super
intricate so this particular mechanic
was made by one of our designers
I decided just to graduate it out of out
of USC and it's a fantastic mechanic all
of us the first thing we said was like
well that's like a real game right let's
repeal confront of course it's a real
game right but then the next level of
this which people took this and remixed
it and started adding more and more
level and it's to the point now where
the creator's having trouble like
completing a level five because it's
just like and it's an infuriatingly
simple mechanic and it's just super-fun
and then the second thing is remixes so
all clogged loaded up the epic castle
level where somebody took the castle
said that we provided which had a bunch
of like interesting casual pieces and
just took it to the next level we're
like huge huge creation see this is more
like last time I saw a demo project
spark it was showing how to make like a
fantasy action role-playing game
obviously you look at this and you get
kind of a fable vibe singing those 2d
puzzle games and a pinball game that's
why that stuff is crazy because like
this is what I imagined when I we're not
necessarily this but like freely like
that you know 3d action behind a game
yeah like the language in Spock is
extremely flexible it's like any
programming language that you can make
whatever comes to mind we chose the to
focus on fantasy in what we provide and
will be showed first because fantasy
makes people think I lpg a-- a
storytelling depth and it's it's
something that people have a very fond
memories of there's also very
underserved genre they're not a lot of
great fantasy role-playing games right
now we have creators in spark that are
setting out to do the next great fantasy
role-playing game and they treat it like
Steam greenlight meaning they go out and
they have launched on website the story
is there this character description
there's a wiki about what the game is
going to be some of the pieces of being
shown as they're building them but it's
an epic undertaking they're gonna make a
real lack of your lap ug here's another
great example in the community this is a
girl has been really active since the
beginning of the community but this is
just an odd exploration but in in this
discovery like I learned something about
our engine that I didn't know I had no
idea I could do this I still don't
understand how the ground was exactly
done maybe it's just colored light I
don't know if it is then is the most
so this guy did neither noodle nor
anything like he just got added he
recreated the first he recreated the opl
question favor one I like shot by shot
like every building every dialogue line
everything it's a he say a guy from from
the UK web designer never done the game
before and they were programmed before
doesn't particularly think that he's
particularly technical anything he made
like what the line had team goes that is
the most amazing piece of fanart we've
ever seen like they sent him the xbox
anniversary edition and like the table
anniversary edition xbox like the
printed one and a letter from Deline
head clue about how amazing this and his
notoriety is in the community it's just
like an cemented right authorities the
second measure is that people like
heroes of the community emerge when
people are just fantastic right is the
that is not about us it's about the
people that made this right we should be
a platform like you to more than we
should be a game right so that's the
those are the two big things right yeah
that it's good stuff people have fun and
then just like the stars emerging that
sort of overshadow us right st at the
creators of this again alright sex well
thank you very much for showing us some
of the user-generated content we've seen
some pretty crazy stuff so far what are
you guys's plans in terms of like
further updates to the beta and act
full-on release will be coming up with
the beta fights which one on the fourth
match as i mentioned then next up is
multiplayer will be showing that as soon
as we can but that's the other leg off
of the game right we're now you get to
make and create together which is just
epic like wow the the other part like
we're with no leader boards and we're
working on level linking so you can make
your magnum opus 50 level creation but
beyond that then I think it's time to
take the bait attack off once you get
there sort of waiting for feedback from
the community see what we're missing and
and we'll go as broad as as we can but
right now we have extremely happy with
where we are extremely happy with like
what people are making and we're just
trying to listen to see like one which
would you be next up for the community
alright sounds good and until then the
Eye of Sauron will be watching you thank
you